The word "peace" may have different meanings to different people.
To many, peace is what enables development...
...and is critical in providing opportunities to young people.
To some, especially to those from regions involving conflict,...
...peace keeping and efforts to preserve peace...
...are absolutely vital in bringing prosperity and hope for the future.
To me, peace represents a state of mind, being at peace with yourself.
I believe that when you are at peace with yourself, both mentally and physically,...
...you can achieve anything.
Peace is what allows us, especially young people, to dream,...
...go after one's goals, and prepare you for the next challenge in life.
There is a saying,...
..."Where there is peace, there is culture. Where there is culture, there is peace."
However, as an athlete and figure skater, I would like to say,...
..."Where there is peace, there is sports. Where there is sports, there is peace."
The International Day of Peace provides a valuable opportunity for everyone...
...to observe peace together.
As we come together in unity,...
...let us take a moment to reflect on what each of us can do...
...to build peace around the world. Thank you!